people tend to overestimate what they
can do in a year but wait underestimate
what they can do in 10 years
getting those first customers getting
that first round of funding
can be incredibly difficult but as you
do start to accomplish those things
the benefit of it adds up over time and
you're able to actually get to the place
where you are actualizing those dreams
i'm chas sims ceo and co-founder of y
systems where we are trying to help
increase the number of perfect
deliveries in the world we provide a
platform that helps schedule and plan
routes for drivers that are doing last
mile delivery and we help those drivers
be more on time
more efficient and really just change
the way that all these companies are
doing their deliveries on a daily basis
starting a company is all about
sacrifice and that sacrifice really can
start to look like sleepless nights and
working on the weekends and everything
but really i think one of the biggest
parts is just
sacrificing my vision for how i thought
life would go when my wife and i first
got married a few years ago
it was actually two weeks later that i
had to move to detroit a thousand miles
away
to move into an apartment where i would
be sleeping on the floor and i'd be
living with my co-founder
that was how we got started it really is
all about the sacrifice and laying
everything down for the business
[Music]
for me the american dream means getting
to work on a really
interesting exciting challenging problem
getting to work with people that you
really like genuinely enjoy
being around and respect it's getting to
have that a huge impact
on people's lives and really getting to
be in an industry that is changing
and constantly updating and adjusting
when i was growing up i didn't actually
know that you could even go into
entrepreneurship or start your own
company
and so being able to be that positive
role model for the younger generations
and people
growing up in america that's big